-Our next guest became
the youngest woman
ever to win a gold medal
in the half pipe
at the 2018 Winter Olympics.
And soon you can see her
competing for gold again
at the 2022 Winter Games
in Beijing.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome the one
and only Chloe Kim.
Yeah!
Come on! What!
-Chloe!
-Hello. Hi.
-Thank you so much
for doing this
and taking the time
to come see us
before you're in
the Winter Olympics,
I mean, opening ceremonies
are a week away.
Thanks for doing the show.
How are you feeling right now?
What's going through your head?
-Oh my gosh, it's so crazy.
Like, it's been insane.
I actually got all of
my Olympic gear today,
so I'm really excited did a
little runway show in my house.
-Yeah.
-But it feels so real.
It's been four years already.
-It feels like just yesterday,
kind of.
I mean, I I have a photo here
that I wanted to show a view
at six years old
just so everyone can see.
It starts young. I mean, look at
you 6 years old, that cute?
And yeah, and then, yeah,
just to go from there
to this person right here.
How awesome is that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
After you won, you go like,
"You know what,
I'm going to take a break
from snowboarding for a second,
I'm going to go to college."
And everyone was like,
"What?
No, no, no. You know, you have
to win more medals and do more."
And you go,
"No, I don't actually.
I can make my own decisions
and make my own choices,
and I'm going to go to school."
And I was like,
"Yeah, respect."
I love that you did that.
-Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, school is such
an awesome experience.
I had so much fun.
It was just nice to like,
chill and not be sore every day.
That was the first thing
I noticed. I was like,
Oh my gosh, I had a very
eventful day and I'm not sore.
Yeah, like, when does
that ever happen to me?
So it was really nice.
Then I met,
I met some amazing people
and it was just
an amazing experience.
I'm so happy I did that.
-What did you major in?
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah. Talk to me.
-So I went, So oh my gosh. Okay.
So I went and thinking
I was going to do chemistry.
-Oh my gosh. Alright.
-Yeah.
-And that didn't work out?
-No.
-Yeah.
-Definitely not.
-Now what is it?
What'd it change to?
-Yeah. So now I think
I'm going to do anthropology.
I think.
I-I don't even know.
Like, I think that's
the whole point, though, like,
I don't know, but it's awesome.
I love that I don't know.
Maybe I'll just like, make
a decision super last minute
when I have to.
Like, maybe I'll do computer
science. I don't know.
Like, I barely like, know how to
turn my computer on, but maybe.
-That was my major. That was me.
I was computer science.
That was my major.
-No way. Really?
-Don't be -- why are you
that surprised?
-No, it's just I a lot of
my friends that computer science
and they just looked miserable
every day. So I don't know.
I applaud you for doing that,
but that's amazing.
-They ended up changing my major
and yeah, I of course,
I end up majoring
in anthropology.
-Oh, yeah.
I think you should go
into, like, fashion.
-That's what I want to do.
-This is like I'm a mind reader.
-I really want to do that.
Yeah, I just don't even know
where to start.
I actually made my own
like snow collection with Roxy,
which was such a fun experience
and really inspired me
to maybe go and do it.
But I do like.
Why don't you do once you
come up with the fashion line
and sell your stuff
at the store, Anthropologie?
-Oh my God.
-And there you go.
Get them all out of the way.
You win, win. It's a win win.
-Oh my God.
-It's a win win, buddy.
Call me whatever you want to.
I'll give you the best advice.
-I will.
Maybe you can help me
with the computer stuff
behind the scenes.
Yeah, I'll put you
in touch with someone.
This is on honor, right?
Cover of "Time" magazine.
And it's unbelievable
that you can't beat that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You don't think, you don't think
you can beat that,
but then comes along this...
Cinnamon Toast Crunch, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is the biggest honor.
I mean, are you a --
I'm assuming you're a
Cinnamon Toast Crunch fan?
It was actually concerning.
Because when I was a kid,
I would eat a box a day
and my parents would buy them
in bulk pretty much,
and I would just
go through them.
So they stopped
buying it for me.
And here I am now.
I can have as much as I want
because I'm an adult.
-That's right. Thank you.
Exactly right.
[ Applause ]
Chloe, you know,
we're the biggest fans here
rooting for you.
And here's what I what I wanted
to just put out open end
whenever you want after you
win the gold. Take time off.
Do whatever you want.
When you come back to see me,
let's let's have
a bowl of cereal
and talk about the win.
Okay, bud?
Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
-That would be so fun.
Let's do it.
-Alright, bud. We love you.
We're rooting for you.
I'm so happy you represent
the United States.
Chloe Kim right there.
The 2022 Winter Olympic Games
begin February 4th.